hello who you hello I'm Louise just
another emotional strength hello it's
Nick
- cheerful is that it's a chemical
reactor
Jack off you go with the story um it was
a few years ago now but I was living in
New Zealand at the time and when you're
young and single you download this thing
called tinder and I went on a date a
first time and first experience date
went well got invited to a house party
on the Friday night at the house party I
was big crook because I'd had dumb carry
for lunch with my workmates and so I did
disappear to the bathroom for a little
bit yes and I had ruined my underwear
which I took off very quickly and I
couldn't manage to hide them apart from
this big rack on the back of the door
and I just hid them and went back to the
party about an hour later the mother of
the boy whose party it was who I'd never
met holds up a pair of white underwear
and says whose are these stops the music
we're all staying there I'm like could
you believe someone would do that but
the data mine she says aw that's
disgusting
one thing leads to another iran denies
it we go back to my place date two and
walk in past my housemate we get to my
room one things done to lead to another
and then she very quickly realized as I
was getting undressed slowly that I
didn't have underwear on she looked at
me and went those were yours weren't
they yep and she walked out and my
flatmate yelled from a kitchen he's like
gee bro that was quick
oh hi there Mike what's your name I met
Edie yeah and were you from in
stoke-on-trent stoke-on-trent and what
do you do it I'm a software consultant a
software consultant Kylie on it off you
go with the story so earlier on in my
career I had my first proper job
interview and obviously I was quite
nervous I'd heard some tales about the
person due to interview me and she was a
bit of a terror so I turned up ten
minutes early in a place that I wasn't
really familiar with waited about half
an hour she was quite late so I've
started phoning and I phoned her once
and I'm not very good on the phone and
didn't really want to do this phoned her
again and then decided last second I
really need the toilet so I put the
phone in my pocket ran into the toilet
came out pulled the phone out to see if
she'd phoned me and the phone was
recording on to her voicemail
absolutely everything I come back to the
room she's there she's about to pick up
her phone no no please don't pick up
your phone please interview it went
horribly a somehow managed to get the
job and to this day I still don't know
if she said it piri-piri
yep like the chicken
every phone call he makes
like the chicken where you from period
New Zealand that I live in London now oh
right what do you do in London
I work for a media organisation of a
care Peri Peri Peri okay so my dad's a
visa from New Zealand he works in the
film industry um at the end of each day
that they film they watch what are
called rushes so essentially what you
film that day anyway so one day when I
was a teenager I was working on a big
film and he went to watch rushes as he
usually does and then he was having
trouble putting Jetix work on slap talk
so it gets one of the producers to come
up and help him anyway they fill away
with laptop and then all this gay porn
comes up what on earth is going on this
is not mind but he looks at his
colleague there looks a laptop it's like
there's no way they're gonna believe me
if I deny it so he just grin and bear it
and um anyway it was mine became my
coming-out story and to this day they
think it's his
[Applause]
I'm with you but no you're better you're
walking you're walking
hello hello hi what's your name my name
is Eleanor Eleanor lovely and where you
from Eleanor I'm from Macclesfield
Macclesfield ideas still live in
Macclesfield no I live in London
oh and that what you do in London I'm a
surveyor I serve their she surveys yeah
okay off you go be the story okay so
it's a bit of a coincidence and today
earlier today I was at work and I was
just shouting over to my colleague
rambling on and he thought that I said I
want that one and so that was my
impression of you Matt Lucas I'm sorry
[Applause]
cruel and heartless you are
it's the opportunity to tell your
funniest story I'm sure she thought for
longer something funnier must have
happened to her but I think she was just
struck by the coincidence yeah that you
were here it was it was hello hi hi
what's your name Aaron Aaron okay my
brother Aaron
Wellington sorry lovely okay off you go
with the story so I was seen someone was
about 20 on my lunch break I took about
smiling quickly after finished I rolled
over stretched out dear sir Kate my
shoulder and she had to call the
ambulance wait for the ambulance tell my
work why wasn't coming back
dressed me as well which does in
excruciating pain and then I've never
seen her again
[Applause]
now they say television doesn't affect
you for far too long some people live
everyone dies
no sir come on hi what's your name Peter
Peter lovely and that where you from
Peter I'm from Weymouth Weymouth and
what's he doing women i portrait monkey
world at monkey world now now you're not
gonna slip him he works at monkey world
this is going to be a story and a half
okay do not touch this sophie Turner
okay okay he works at monkey world
monkey world monkey well imagine how
good this story's going to be it sounds
he works at monkey world let me just
check this is your story concerning
monkey world No
[Applause]
okay we're feeling very good about you
what's your name
Naomi Naomi lovely Emily and what do you
do I work for a charity
she works for a charity she's got you
there I work for a charity okay where're
you from Australia Australia Australia
sure it's for charity
her name's Naomi the story starts now
okay so when I was about four years old
it was Christmas Eve and we went to a
mass was it a huge Cathedral and the
priest called all the children up to the
front like oh my family's there where
did baby Jesus come from I know the
answer hand shoots up take the
microphone from my mum's vagina
Cathedral the echo of vagina vagina safe
to say I've never lived that one down
[Applause]
[Music]
you